I'll make Oh madam how are you
alaikum assalam I'm doing very good
thanks for having me on the show how you
been I'm the love Airy good so what
you're keeping busy last time we had you
in it was Jesus and Muhammad Jesus and
the last messenger the prophet Salih
Solomon yes that was what ass book
that's right yeah because when you
accept Muhammad as the last and final
messenger sent to mankind as a mercy to
mankind you automatically accept Jesus
Moses a band all the preceding
messengers absolutely correct and now
tell us about the new book hamdullah the
new book is called the greatest man of
all time a mercy to the world and it is
a true story that over a billion people
love around the world now wait stop stop
right there
you said something great it's very
exciting said look if you want to make
but somebody's out there talking about
let's make America great again how you
going to make America or the world great
again if you don't get to know who the
Prophet Muhammad Salla some the greatest
man of all time you want to make America
great again you have to learn about the
greatest man of all time and this is a
man the reason why he's the greatest man
of all time is that he was a model
businessman he was a fun up phenomenal
finet philanthropist he was a just
military commander he was in an
influential political leader he was a
beloved spouse a nurturing parent and an
ultimate peacemaker we struggle in our
lives to just do two of these things
well and he had half a dozen to a dozen
roles where he excelled and he showed us
the best example so whether it's
Democrat Republican Trump Clinton the
Green Party candidate the Libertarian
Party candidate politicians non
politicians they need to pick up the
story of the Prophet SAW wasalam and
this is done in a way that appeals to
Muslims and non-muslims the way that
it's branded and we really they need to
have this as a core part of their
knowledge base and they're reading how
do you some people have heard of him but
they've heard of him in such a distorted
misinformed way how do you deal with
those people say well I've already
uncovered enough the fact that his
marriage
is or you know him being in so many wars
that he was you know a violent person
that he did all kinds of evil things
this is the distorted view right and he
says the distorted and they say you know
what I don't need to get I don't need to
go much further
what would you say something to someone
like that the truth will set you free
and you just need to pick up this book
the way that it's branded you know a lot
of books on the life of the Prophet SAW
huh some biographies they they breed
like history books may Allah reward the
people that wrote those books we took an
approach of using indirect references at
the beginning instead of starting out
with the Prophet Muhammad Allah someone
from the beginning we call them the
messenger instead of calling Makka by
its name we call it the city and these
are all things that were okay with the
scholars like Sheikh Nasser cloudy who
we talked about too in the first book
and sheikh omar soliman who reviewed the
entire first book and so you know to
answer your question folks just need to
pick up the story read it in an unbiased
fashion and that's the way we approached
it right we didn't put a picture you
know of the Kaaba although that is the
holiest of lands people's guards go up
their defenses go up they go blind deaf
they don't want to consider the message
so you have to do it in a way that is
going to be inviting appealing and
invite them in in a way that they will
consider it and not reject it
immediately yeah and if you put things
in context you know people you know
usually the winners they say of history
rewrite history and then there has been
a strong push to suppress this truth
coming out the true life of problem how
many peace be upon them and if you you
know if you talk about battles they are
just Wars and you would see him as
actually a liberator as a man of justice
as a man of peace you know never having
we talked about marriage he didn't
promote promiscuity absolutely something
that was there or more of the best of
morality so anything that you can try to
bring do will be of the highest morals
he exemplified that in the highest state
you'll be robbing yourself by not
getting to know this man absolutely
you'd be doing yourself an injustice if
you didn't try to understand this story
and there's a lot of resource
is out there but the main thing is to
pick up one where you're going to have
fun you're going to have a good time
there's a lot of books out there that
people read and they don't have a ton of
value to them you know I have a lot of
friends family that I've read for
example Harry Potter that's a great read
but you're not going to drive a ton of
value from it you need to read something
where you're going to learn we're going
to become stronger I my day job is in
corporate America and there's a lot of
people that spend millions and millions
of dollars right in corporations to
develop effective leaders you don't need
to spend that much money you can you can
get it for practically free by
understanding Islam reading the Quran
and reading the serial serie of the
prophets Allah some of the life story of
the prophets Allah Solomon you can read
this book the greatest man of all time
to have a fun engaging effective way of
understanding how to be a really
excellent leader among other things you
see these dirty tricks being played
nowadays it's been played before is
played today these ad hominem attacks
that go directly had a person you know
to try to discredit him lies deception
deceit you know to try to get people
away from the message that the person is
bringing there was I don't know if you
saw this movies called kill the
messenger have you heard of this
journalist was exposing some truth that
was out there and he got a call from
someone and he said look be prepared to
be controversial eyes I never heard that
type of controversial eyes I mean
they're coming after you they're going
to attack you personally everything that
you uncovered of truth they're going to
forget about that we kind of see that
here happening with with with the
greatest man that had ever absolutely
taking his life Slama phobia it's not a
full time right billions of dollars get
spent to discredit and slam Islam but
the thing that Muslims need to be at
peace with and I've said this to many
family and friends that Allah has
guaranteed that Islam will be victorious
and the question for us in these
difficult times is not so much do I want
to go into the shadows but do I want to
be a part of this victory do I want to
get on this bus that is headed towards
victory because by the end of the
century when you talk to demographers
people that track population trends by
the end of this century Muslims will be
the
most numerous people there outnumber
Christians it will outnumber any other
faith and it's not going to be about the
quantity brother Eddie it's about the
quality understanding who the prophets
alehsalaam is understanding the Koran
and staying true to our beliefs even in
these times of fitna and difficulty and
you can understand that when we say
Islam submission to the will of the
Creator not the Christian will be
victorious because God created creation
he sent out of his love the way we need
to live and Jesus brought it Moses
brought it Mohammed brought it that's
the complete adherence to loving God
with all your heart your mind your body
so how do you learn by submitting to
your Creator that's how you get it and
that's going to be victorious at the end
that's right we right back with more of
the author adam rahman the greatest man
of all time problem honk peace be upon
them get to know this man when you talk
about more about the book don't go
anywhere
back here on the Dean show tell us a
little bit Adam you as seen at ABC NBC
Fox tell us about how you got was you
were on there with the book how was this
hamdullah so earlier this year you know
we've seen a lot of coverage of the
presidential election Clinton versus
Trump versus you know two other
candidates Libertarian candidate Green
Party candidate and Donald Trump was
calling for a Muslim ban in the into
this country I was born in the United
States I lived in Saudi Arabia for eight
years I love the United States
I love makkah medina I love Alice Fonda
thought oh I love the prophet mohammed
salah salem more than any other person
past present or future and this really
got under the skin of a lot of folks in
my community you know we're productive
peaceful citizens we want to see America
continue to be great and so my nonprofit
organization awake I revival it's a
501c3 nonprofit organization we issued a
press release calling Donald Trump out
and basically if he wants to make
America great again we said in the
statement you got to get to know the
greatest men of all time a mercy to the
world and as a result of just doing that
that action for the sake of Allah we got
picked up by over 200 media
organizations around the world I know
that and the four big television
networks ABC NBC CBS FOX have us
featured and so this is I'm they'll
allow you you try to do something for
the sake of God the Creator not the
creation and fantastic excellent things
happen that's amazing it reminds me
because when people can relate and they
can understand that when we talk about
problem Hamid peace be upon him
automatically Jesus is hooked up in
there Abraham Moses all of the greatest
men to ever walk the earth you know and
there's one saying this hadith that
problem Hamid he describes a beautiful
please be upon him of a beautiful house
brick house mansion with you know the
beyond what you can imagine of beauty
and people walking around it and then
they stopped at the corner and said hey
there's one piece missing here as a
brick missing here he said I am that
brick alright you know this hadith this
statement so that's all it is it's a
completion because what we have a
revelation today many has been distorted
edited you know tamper with but that's
why God out of his love sent Prophet
Muhammad the greatest man of all time
out of his love to guide humanity to
that which is pleasing to God he's the
final messenger tell us something else
in your book what people can expect when
they go into the whole serie his whole
life is comfortably absolutely into your
point he is the seal of the messengers
so all the prophets the messengers
before that Allah sent them to the world
two nations two countries two different
people and many a community rejected
those messengers and prophets and the
people that accepted musa alehsalaam
moses who accepted esata saddam Jesus
and the prophets Allah seldom you know
over time essentially there were
distortions you know in Christianity and
Judaism and that's why Islam came to us
it came to us to be essentially superior
to all other religions this is written
you know in the Quran and in the book
itself it's a bigger better bolder
version of my first book I'm know that
there's over 200 sources that we we took
a look at to put this together
and it's written in a story-based form
it's all nonfiction I was particularly
inspired by one of my favorite scholars
Sheikh EOS Arkady and he spent over
three years doing over 100 lectures in
the life of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu I saw them and I was just so
inspired by it I mean after the first
book is getting a lot of good feedback a
lot of good reception being on the top
1% of the Amazon best-selling list but I
wasn't satisfied with that I will not be
satisfied with these efforts and tell
all people around the world except Islam
so in reviewing additional material from
shakey Arkady and the Tufts here in the
Quran and the sayha deeds we wanted to
have
a more extended unabridged version so my
first book it's an abridged version of
the life of the prophets alehsalaam
and this second book now the greatest
man of all time more miracles more
engaging more fun no backed by over 120
very influential people around the world
in United States and Canada and Mexico
outside of the West as well and so we've
gotten a lot of good reception there's
Congress men Congress women that that
know about these efforts that our
organizations been doing so we really
want to continue to reach out to
politicians to Christians to Jews to to
Muslims and just like we did with the
first effort where we wrote letters to
ten world leaders brother Eddie around
the world and three of them responded
back the president France the Prime
Minister of Canada and the president
Brazil France Brazil Canada from Doha
and they thanked us for the efforts so
three out of ten responded I'm Lola so I
look forward to sending this book around
to even broader lists now that we've
kind of touched down this is the
prophetic tradition right he wrote to
the ruler of Persia he wrote to the
ruler of Byzantium the Roman Empire he
wrote to the ruler that was presiding
over Egypt all around the world it's a
global message we are a global community
and the vast majority of us I think you
had a show on this basically trying to
quantify the percentage of people that
are peaceful versus people that choose
extreme versions that that are not from
our peaceful tradition yeah we are
peaceful people one point seven billion
of us and Counting yeah it's a fastest
growing movement fastest growing
religion the only reason why that's the
case is because the Prophet Muhammad's
alehsalaam the greatest man of all time
he came with the truth and Allah
promised to preserve the Koran it's the
most memorized book in the world most
memorized book in the world and so when
you just look at a few of these facts
hopefully Islam will enter your heart I
am speaking to the Christians and the
Jews that are watching the show right
now and it'll mix in and that is true
religion and I hope that they will
accept Islam and if they don't accept
Islam then at least they will respect
Islam yeah if you're you're a
god-fearing god-loving purpose person
and you are open-minded objective you
know you will look at the evidence look
at the Quran with an open heart open
mind look at the life a problem Muhammad
not to the eyes of some hater some
Islamophobe things we'll uncover you'll
see something so beautiful something so
amazing we'll be right back with more
here today's show don't go anywhere
back here on the Dean show tell us from
studying the life of the last and final
messenger muhammad peace be upon him
tell me what stood out are there you
know there's such a vast array of things
of history is there something that
sticks out right up until now that you
remember that kind of absolutely
increases your Eman and though there's
it's sort of like asking somebody to you
know name their favorite book or their
favorite moment in life you know no life
we're thankful to God to Allah there's
so many to pick from so I'll pick one of
the favorite true stories from his life
and I think this is an important lesson
for our Ummah for a community today to
not go back into the shadows when
there's so much Islamophobia to really
be proud to be Muslim be humble but
proud to be Muslim one of the first
things that the prophet mohammed salah
salem did when he reached medina when
the Quraysh were trying to assassinate
him for his peaceful message Elizabeth
Allah did not give the prophets Allah
solemn permission to fight against them
although they were being very very mean
to him they were trying to take his life
he fled to Medina to seek peace and one
of the first things that he did when he
got there was that he commanded that a
place of Prayer a must should be erected
before he even built his own house right
he stayed with some extended family
members so that the must should the
mosque a place of Prayer could be
erected first and then he also asked
where is the where does the buying and
selling happen the local bazaar where
merchants do their commerce and he was
told that all the Jewish community is
running it there's nothing wrong with
that but he wanted the transactions to
be more pure to be more hell out
permissible for there not to be other
taking advantage of exactly interest is
not for Burma ceilings that exact make
sure there's a sir destroyed fairness
and fairness right and wrong quality
fairness when you're trading buying and
selling so the prophet sala sell them
the other thing that he did was he
commanded that a local Bazaar the the
local economy
for the Muslims be established and
obviously non-muslims could also conduct
commerce there
so in summary one of my favorite moments
is when he got to Medina
he commanded that the must should be
built and that a local Bazaar be built
and let me extrapolate this to the year
2016 in this time when where some of us
are struggling with certain jobs with
other things in life we need to be brave
we need to have courage just like you
have your own television show you're an
example to a lot of us in the community
Muslim non-muslim we need more people to
be like you like fellow businessmen that
are entrepreneurs to start our own
businesses to start our own schools to
start own pharmacies to start our own
political party we need to and I'm not
saying cut off from society be
isolationist we need to be integrated
the best way to spread Islam is not by
the sword the best way to spread Islam
is by showing good character go to local
food bank pass out food if there's
somebody that's homeless give them give
them money right don't be stingy by
integrating by mixing with society but
sitting true to your identity and by
starting our own efforts or own emotions
our own businesses our own schools so
that we can teach the leadership lessons
the merciful nature that the Prophet
Sawa's Elam exemplified as the greatest
man of all time we can learn those
lessons the current educational
curriculum I'm a product of it I went to
public schools including elementary
school high school University and also
graduate school they don't teach in a
fair and balanced way about all the
religions and I was talking to our local
congresswoman in California I was in a
roundtable discussion with several
religious leaders and she was very
interested in trying to see if we could
inject some fair balanced religious
education you just present the facts and
I hope that we can start with that and
expand to other things so that we can
peacefully spread the message of Islam
are the news is a this is a great
example if everybody would do their part
obviously our job is just to share
because if you care you share
and that's going to help to alleviate
some of the fears and Miss information
that people have that they've been
victim fallen victim to because of this
Islamophobia machine that's out there so
if everybody does their small part like
you're doing we're trying to do
everybody is an individual as and with
organizations get out there try to make
the human connection invite people to
the Masjid help people to get to know
truly what Muslims are about what Islam
is about they'll see more I mean people
really it resonates just a simple basic
beliefs of Islam
you know the worship of the Creator not
the creation you know doing good deeds
you know trying to be a best moral
ethics and character to deal in business
justly to help those who are less
fortunate to you down and trottin you
know just there's nothing in Islam you
know especially when you look at problem
how many Peaks be upon life you see like
not only is the Quran a living miracle
that we have it nor the book like it in
the world but Prophet Muhammad's life
when you see you know you can you can
spot a sheister mile away man when you
really looked at a diva you wrote his
you know you wrote this book and you see
it's a miracle when you study his life
you see like why is he doing this you
know I mean if you just look at the dew
or the fortress of the most of the dwama
book it's a fantastic book he's like I
mean not only the Quran if he put that
together like some people say what's he
doing I mean everything they're they're
recording his life you know out today to
have the reality shows and every cameras
everywhere where you go all eyes were on
him and all he was calling people do or
like prepare for the next life obey the
one who created you before you meet him
do good deeds be just be fair be right
it's amazing I'm told uh absolutely and
you know some of the miracles that
occurred and there's many miracles in
the court and the revelations that he
received from God because people accuse
the prophet muhammad's alehsalaam of
writing the Quran he didn't know how to
read or write yeah he didn't know how to
read or write and in that time the
stories of prophets in the past messages
in the past they didn't have that
knowledge and so when he was challenged
by the court age with help from the
Jewish community to basically pull
certain quest
the prophets Allah Salaam about people
of times past messengers of times past
Elizabeth Allah eventually sent
revelation to answer and there's no way
that a man that could not have read or
written and didn't have that education
could have known those stories so
there's no way he made it up and the
other thing that I want to share with
your viewers brother Eddie is that if
you read this book the greatest man of
all time you will see a connection
between the quota and the examples in
his life the historical examples in his
life written in a true non fictional
story based form which is very fun and
you will see the connection between the
events that happen in his life and as
the Quran was being revealed before
things would even happen
alla Spina thought would foreshadow and
predict these things were going to
happen and then later when they happened
it was a miracle being witnessed over
and over and over and although were
fourteen centuries removed these things
happen and there were too many witnesses
president at present too many witnesses
present and too much documentation he's
the most well one of the most
well-documented leaders of all time and
if you just give it a chance
I am humbly confident that you will be
intrigued and that insha'Allah God
willing the message of Islam will enter
your heart and for Muslims where maybe
they've gone a little bit far from the
message it will reinvigorate where we're
out of time where can people get the
book they can get the book on amazon.com
on amazon.com it's available for
pre-order right now until the November
18 2016 launch November 18th we're going
to launch and then after that they're
welcome to order it as well on Amazon
thank you once again it's a pleasure to
have you on the program just okhla has
that cool account and you guys make sure
you want to make America great hey focus
on first making your life great again
and how you going to make your life
great again or even the world great
again let alone America if you don't
know the greatest man who ever walked
the earth problem Hamid peace and
blessings be upon him who's a brother to
Jesus Moses Abraham all the messengers
who call people to establish a direct
connection with the one who created
create
God Almighty thank you so I'm making
peace